today on the matt wall show a new online
trend has some people declaring
themselves
super straight the left has condemned it
as transphobic but then again
they condemn everything as transphobic
also five headlines including
blm protesters fighting against racism
by harassing little girls on their way
to a cheerleading competition
minneapolis braces for rioting as the
derek chovan trial begins
and lonely people have given rise to a
new trend cow cuddling
plus in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss a pastor who got himself fired
after he gave a sermon telling women
that they
have a responsibility to look attractive
to their husbands did he have a point
i'll see how many people i can tick off
when we discuss that and much more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
now in recent days a new trend online
has provoked increasing concern from the
left and the media the trend is called
super straight
this is a new sexual orientation hot off
the presses
though not really new at all uh invented
by a tick tock user in a video that has
since been removed i'm not sure if he
removed it himself or
tick tock took it down as hate speech
certainly the left has declared the
video hate speech an article posted to
yahoo
bears the headline a social media trend
has people identifying as super straight
the transphobic campaign was meant to
divide lgbtq people
and pink news declares transphobic trend
superstrate has links to the far right
and neo-nazis
of course because everything does the
website distractify says
social media users explain how super
straight is transphobia
not a sexuality and the article comes
with a warning for those who didn't get
the message from the headline
that quote transphobic statements are
ahead
before we go any further um i guess we
should probably watch the video so let's
watch the video
that started all the commotion here it
is yo guys i made a new sexuality now
actually it's called super straight
okay since straight people or straight
men is myself i get called transphobic
because i wouldn't date a trans woman
you know they're like would you date a
trans woman i'm like no
why that's a female uh no like that's
not a real woman to me like i want real
woman no you're just transphobic
so now i'm super straight i only date
the opposite gender
women that are born women so you can't
say i'm transphobic now
because that's just my sexuality you
know
uh pretty edgy stuff so the guy in the
video which
um that yahoo article mentioned earlier
calls a hate and disinformation campaign
that's what they said about that video
it's a hate and disinformation campaign
but he's really just making the point
that he's attracted to females which
means he's not attracted to males
even males who identify as female the
reason for this by the way is that
generally speaking
a human being is sexually attracted to
another human being
based on who that other human being is
not based on what perception the other
human has of themselves
the idea of being attracted to another
person's self-perception
seems absurd incomprehensible because it
is
now i'm not going to go around calling
myself super straight and i don't think
we should make any serious attempt to
turn super straight into a thing
simply because being regular straight a
normal old heterosexual
already means being attracted to members
of the opposite sex to the exclusion of
members of your same sex
even the ones who identify as members of
the opposite sex
coming up with a new term would seem to
surrender this ground and concede that
it's possible for a person to be
straight
and yet also attracted to members of his
biological sex
i don't want to do that so i'm going to
stick with plain old heterosexual to
describe myself but
this super straight thing is more of a
troll than anything else and as a troll
i have to admit it's it's pretty funny
and it makes an important point
and the point is pretty simple two can
play at that game
right if the left can go around
inventing new sexualities out of whole
cloth
then anybody can and if lgbt people can
express
pride in their sexual preference then
anybody can
one of the trending hashtags on twitter
right now is super straight pride
and many of the people using the
hashtags are accusing those who
criticize them of engaging in
super phobia now again it's silly and
really funny but the point is that if
you think this is silly then all of the
other invented sexualities and genders
are just as silly
and so is labeling someone transphobic
or homophobic for criticizing you or
disagreeing with you
the left does not want to add super
straight to the list of sexualities but
keep in mind
this is a list which includes but is not
limited to allosexual
androsexual asexual autosexual bicurious
bisexual demisexual
uh fluid gay gray sexual
gynosexual heterosexual heteroflexible
homo flexible homosexual lesbian
pansexual queer
questioning sapiosexual sex repulse
scoliosexual and spectrous yes
sexual um by the way a demisexual is
just someone who
needs to have an emotional connection to
someone in order to be attracted to them
that's a demisexual if you
if you need you know if you need that
emotional attachment that emotional
connection
in order to feel the attraction so in
other words women
that's women are demisexual a
sapiosexual someone who finds
intelligence attractive
and a gynosexual as the name suggests is
someone who's attracted to the female
body
so in other words a straight man or a
lesbian
an allosexual get this an allosexual
i'm not making this up and i just found
this out this morning
is someone who experiences sexual
attraction
okay if you're attracted to
anyone then you're an allosexual
any sexual attraction at all makes you
an allosexual what this all means is
that the super straight community is
selling itself short i think i mean you
could add a whole bunch of additional
labels
you could be a heterosexual allosexual
gynosexual superstrait
this is how ludicrous it's gotten there
are
there are already lgbt orientations and
pride flags
for people who are straight but for
whatever reason don't want to call
themselves that
i say for whatever reason but i know the
reason the reason is that there is
privilege that comes with being in the
lgbt
camp being under that umbrella okay it's
not it's not
it's not cis heterosexual privilege it's
lgbt privilege that's what we have in
this culture
and that's why straight people invent
sexualities
i mean they they remain straight but
they invent new labels
just so they can fit just so they can be
in the club
and if you have a club that everyone is
desperate to be a part of that's a
pretty good indication that your club is
privileged
that's like the definition of a
privileged club
and all of these sexualities interact
with the ever expanding list of genders
now this is certainly but a partial
catalogue but that list includes
agender androgynine androgynous bigender
cisgender gender fluid
gender non-conforming gender questioning
gender variant genderqueer intersex
non-binary pan gender trans female trans
male trans person
trans woman trans feminine trans
masculine to spirit and other
and like i said very partial list
matching up a sexuality with a gender is
like a march madness bracket they're
like
98 trillion possible outcomes and all
these different words and labels are
only meant to obscure the fact that in
reality
you know it all still boils down to the
same basic quote traditional
possibilities when it comes to sexual
orientation
the left has simply found a hundred
different ways to repeat itself
but they hasten to remind you only they
are allowed to do that
this is a game that only they are
allowed to play they can invent genders
invent sexualities express
great pride in their new creations you
cannot they say
you're not allowed according to their
rules and that's a very good reason to
break their rules and do it anyway just
to annoy them
i mean for no other reason so i'm a
supporter of the super straight movement
for that reason alone in fact i think we
could invent some more i mean the sky is
the limit
maybe we come up with um different
sexualities based on the day of the week
if you're attracted to somebody on a
tuesday you're a two's to sexual
if it's wednesday you're a wednesday
sexual of course fried sexual will be a
popular identification
i suspect there won't be a lot of
mundasexuals is this completely stupid
sure but the people who talk about
demisexuals and allosexuals
you know have no room to criticize and
that's the point
two can indeed play at this game and if
you don't like it
then maybe we should all stop playing it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to five headlines today i
want to tell you about our friends over
at lifelock
you know it's always a good time to
think about protecting yourself
online protecting yourself from identity
theft
especially now with the tax deadline
approaching it's important to take steps
to avoid being a victim
of tax scams or a lot of them out there
cyber criminals have used social
security numbers to file fake
returns in an attempt to steal refunds
so you file early be aware of suspicious
activities
related to your return and find out if
you're eligible to apply for an irs
identity protection pin
this is just one of the ways that cyber
crime identity theft are affecting our
lives
it's important to understand all the
different ways that it's affecting us
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal can harm what's yours your
finances your credit they can take
everything from you
good thing there's life luck life lock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
being for sale in the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they'll
send you an alert
and they're just going to make it very
easy for you to protect yourself
because it's really easy for identity
thieves to take your identity
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions in all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join now and save it 25 off your first
year by going to lifelock.com
walls that's lifelock.com welsh to save
25
all right and i apologize if you're
watching the the show and i i seem
you know more stiff and uncomfortable
than usual
it's because i woke up with a back
injury that i suffered while sleeping
and so i'm officially this is a very
recent thing for me i guess kind of
exciting
you know a level of maturation and
growth as a person
um when you really know that's what you
officially reach adulthood
is when you wake up with injuries that
you sustained
while lying on a mattress sleeping and
i'm at that point it's a new thing
pretty exciting also painful all right
um
so the trial for officer derek chovin is
set to begin in minneapolis
and the city is already preparing for
rioting
um which you know
what what what does that what does that
tell you
what does that tell you if you're in the
group um if you're
you know in blm or if you're in if you
are among the people
uh hoping that derek chovin is convicted
then it's already known ahead of time
that if your side gets upset you're
gonna riot like what does that tell you
about your side
when it's the same thing that happened
around the election time right
when cities have to have to board up
shop and they have to if they
have to shut down and they got to bring
in the national guard ahead of time and
all that kind of stuff because they're
worried that you might get upset
that should tell you something about
your side
and if it's not clear by now what it
tells you is that you're not the good
guys
pretty that's a that's a you know that's
that's pretty good indication
and this is all why i just don't see um
i i don't know how this trial is going
to go it's hard for me to see how he
could possibly get a fair trial
especially
in minneapolis if they don't change the
location of the trial which doesn't look
like they're going to
how how could he possibly get a fair
trial
because everyone in that jury is going
to know um
they're they're going to know it's it's
very clear that you know if he's
acquitted
or even if he you know probably even if
he's found guilty on a lesser charge
let's say he's found guilty on
manslaughter but not on murder
well blm they're going to dox the jurors
they're going to find out who those
jurors were and they're going to destroy
their lives
if not worse so you know that as a juror
sitting on that jury you know that if
you unless you've been living in a cave
unless you've been unconscious for the
last uh
three years four years certainly for the
last
eight or nine months you know that's the
way it's gonna go
that you listen to the facts and if the
facts tell you to acquit
you know that if you if that's the vote
that you cast that's the decision you
make
um it could ruin your life
you are going to be public enemy number
one and they're going to try to find you
and hunt you down
so it would require it would require for
that jury
to to uh if the facts show that he
should be acquitted for the jury to make
that decision would require
immense personal courage on their part
which maybe they have that kind of
courage the thing is most people don't
nothing against people on jury i don't
know who they are but most that's why
that that's why we admire personal
courage because it's kind of a rare
quality so we'll see meanwhile speaking
of blm this is from the courier journal
says a racial justice protest outside
the kentucky international convention
center over the weekend
has drawn criticism from some community
members who say demonstrators should not
have targeted children entering a cheer
competition
well some community members say that
there's some communities
that members are saying maybe you don't
target kids
some and then of course there are plenty
on the pro
targeting kids side uh it says for
several hours saturday a group of about
30 protesters walked around outside the
downtown building chanting into
megaphones and calling on sparkly
dressed kids to recognize their white
privilege
video from the scene has ignited anger
on social media from residents who say
that city officials should do more to
crack down on protests that have
disrupted louisville's
streets and sidewalks for more than nine
months we have
some of that video let's let's watch
some of it
[Music]
there's something now today with your
white cradles besides cheers
do something blue today with your white
privilege besides cheer
the reason why you get to be here in
these pretty gorgeous houses with your
porch there
or the stone is because of your white
privilege rihanna is dead
this is mental illness you know
that that the response when you've got a
woman screaming into a megaphone
at little kids walking down the street
that's a mentally ill woman she should
be put in a mental asylum
that that's what we need to do with
someone like that
screaming at her about brianna taylor
what the hell do these kids have to do
with brianna taylor
brianna taylor was um
uh was was shot by police accidentally
and so therefore that means that these
little kids can't go to a cheer
competition
connect those dots for me i'd like to
hear you well you can't because you're
insane you're you're a lunatic
if you couldn't understand what you were
saying into the megaphone and this was
if you're what if you're listening to
the audio podcast these were
like little girls in their cheer outfits
going to a chair competition walking
down the street
and then you've got these uh blm
scumbags screaming at them
what do these kids do nothing they're
just kids
it sounded like she said do something
black today with your white privilege
besides cheer and then she also said uh
the reason that you're
that you're able to to participate into
your competition is because of your
white privilege
really so there are no black
cheerleaders huh that's this is a white
thing
cheerleading is a reflection of uh white
privilege so you're telling me
that i'm not going to find any if if if
you were to go into that cheer
competition you're telling me there
wouldn't be
plenty of black cheerleaders there too
really
you know i was saying before if you're
on the side
where cities have to shut down and board
up shop
because they're afraid that they're
going to make you mad that's an
indication that you're
on the wrong side that you're the bad
guy
well here's another good hint if you're
on the side that
does that kind of thing
and it's not like this is some sort of
unique occurrence
this is one of blm's favorite tactics
just walking down the street harassing
completely innocent random people or
simply trying to go about their day
including kids so if you're on the side
that does that
that should tell you something you're
the bad guy
all right number two don lemon reacting
to the megan markel interview said
something pretty revealing yesterday
um about you know something that
revealed something about the the media
mindset the leftist mindset
let's take a listen i thought it was a
fantastic interview
i thought it was eye-opening i think
that um
there was initial initially people
thought that maybe megan and harry
didn't um that they should have waited
it out longer they should have
you know instead of just 18 months that
they could have made a difference inside
the royal family
but once you got a sense and you heard
what they said to oprah about why they
did it then you realize that maybe it
wasn't going to work out for them
and the best thing to do was come to
america do what they did
and speak out and speak out with someone
like oprah i think i thought it was
perfect i think that they
they handled it perfectly it def it
sounded more acute it sounded more like
a crisis uh certainly that they were in
the middle of and we really got a sense
of that brianna also
people say well we haven't heard from
the other side what's the other side
going to say they're going to say of
course we're not racist or whatever but
what did they do
think about their actions they they did
not stand up for
their own because their own was married
to a black woman had a black child
they didn't listen to him inside of the
royal family they let him go they let
him leave the country they wouldn't come
to terms with
what they wanted to do so listen we've
only heard from one side but that one
side at this point
rings very true yeah
don thank you so much i was looking
forward to this conversation you do not
disappoint
that's true he doesn't disappoint except
maybe not
in the way that she means it uh what we
don't he says we don't need to hear the
other side because what are they gonna
say of course they're going to deny it
denying it is what a guilty person would
do
so no reason to listen to the other side
let's uh
let's assume that this story is correct
now this is not shocking at all of
course we know this is how the media
operates okay we from the media's
perspective
we've heard the side that we like we'd
prefer for this to be true
you know it the person we've already
determined is the good guy it paints
them in a good light so
we're gonna assume that we're gonna move
forward with it
no reason to bother with things like
getting to the truth
looking at both sides of it being
objective who needs any of that
this is the news media this is not what
we do here
so exactly what you would expect but um
interesting to hear i'm saying it
say the quiet part out loud as i say
number three from the daily wire says
according to the united uh across
across the united states a growing
number of biological men are competing
in women's sports as anti-discrimination
laws at the federal and state level have
opened the door
for athletes to compete based on the
gender with which they identify
um of course we knew about that it goes
on to talk about four states
that are um in the process of
passing laws to prevent biological males
from
participating in female sports and those
states are south dakota
tennessee mississippi and texas
in the process of passing laws saying
if you're if you're a man you can't
participate in women's sports
which is which is great that those four
states are doing that my question is why
isn't
every republican-controlled state doing
this
better question would be why didn't they
do this
five years ago why did they do this
eight years ago
you know those of us with common sense
and with with with eyes on the front of
our heads that can see
we we saw this coming we knew was going
to get to this point
it was obvious years ago
so every every every
republican-controlled state
should be doing exactly this
and the great thing about this issue and
one of the reasons i talk about it so
much
it's very important it's a very
important issue
because it deals with especially when it
comes to sports
men in women's sports men in women's
locker rooms
um you know you're protecting kids
you're protecting their their sports
you're protecting their safety and their
privacy in the locker rooms
that's important for that reason it's
important also because
we're dealing with fundamental truth
okay with with reality are we going to
be a society that recognizes
basic fundamental realities i think i
think that's pretty damn important
personally to fight for that to fight
for basic reality
so it's important on that on that ground
um
the arguments you can make in favor of
laws like this
are honest are bulletproof unassailable
as in there is actually no argument on
the other side
there is no even semi-coherent argument
for allowing the men into women's sports
no argument has ever been made for it
it's happening
people do argue for it but no one has
ever actually presented an argument for
it
um so it's the right thing you can make
great arguments for it
and it's really popular so
this is an opportunity to take a a a a
really
important stand that will also be
profoundly popular with the public
why not do it it's a win-win-win across
the board
every republican state should be doing
this every elected republican
should be on this issue should be lining
up on this issue talking about it
um so congratulations anyway to south
dakota tennessee mississippi and texas
all right also from the daily wire it
says
the two german shepherds belonging to
president joe biden
and first lady jill biden have been
removed from the white house after
displaying aggressive behavior
cnn reported um major who was adopted by
november 2018 from a from a delaware
animal shelter
had what one of the people described as
a biting incident with a member of the
white house security
the exact condition of the victim is
unknown however the episode was serious
enough that the dogs were
subsequently moved to wilmington
delaware where they remain
i i only wanted to bring this up because
um i
once again i i am vindicated i get a lot
of grief for my anti-dog stances but
dogs are a national security threat so
you your apology accepted from all the
rest of you
in other news the washington post has a
story about uh other animal news
specifically the washington post has a
story about the latest wellness trend
which is called cow cuddling a farm in
arizona has started renting out its cows
to
random strangers who walk in looking to
cuddle a large hairy beast
the article says cow cuddling sessions
which cost 75
an hour are booked until june
owner amy takaha says she gets around 20
calls a day about the service she has
offered for five years
business has picked up dramatically in
the past year
she said they're just like happy pills
just to be around
the nine cattle at her farm include
adorable
an angus steer rescued from a ditch
unicorn who has one eye and one horn
i don't know who wants to hug the is
that the discounted rate
so 75 an hour to hug a cow if you only
got 45 bucks they'll give you the
one-eyed cow
you only got 25 okay we got a
three-legged one in the back we'll bring
that one out
also a miniature cow named muchacha the
bovines will amble over to guests for
hugs and cuddles she said they also like
to roll over on their sides and rest
their heads in people's laps
sometimes a turkey named azalea or a
chicken will come by to join in
participants often become emotional she
said and some even vow to become
vegetarian after looking deep into the
creature's large brown eyes okay
uh three really quick thoughts here one
this does say something very bleak and
and sad
about the state of our culture when
people are turning to cows for
companionship
um and for a break from the loneliness
actually reading the story it
is it's a it's a sad story a lot of
people they're saying how during the the
lockdowns in the pandemic
business has been um has been especially
has been especially strong because
people are so lonely in the lockdowns
and we know in our culture um people are
increasingly rejecting family life
and living on their own or with a
roommate or something
and now they've been locked in their
home from for months on end and and
they're they're they're feeling the
isolation in a very cute way
and now they have to turn to a cow for
companionship
um my second point is or really question
is did the cows consent to this
how do we know how do the cows feel
about this
being being [ __ ] out in this way
for lonely desperate people to come and
uh grope them
and number three i think general
principle
it's it's best not to get so familiar
with your hamburgers
so word of warning just a caution all
right
number five finally a bra broke out at a
bath and body
works store in arizona uh we have the
video
of of this and we have to play it i mean
anytime there's a fight
at a retail store you got to play this
is important stuff let's play the video
here
this is at the bath and body works in
arizona
okay it's between it looks like it's
between originally it's between an
employee and a customer
both female all the people involved are
female
there's now about four women five women
at bath and bodies have
jumped onto the dog pile
looks like it's like three employees
versus one customer oh then another
another customer jumps in
we have not seen a a real punch thrown
okay now
so the reason for this i think i i was i
was trying to figure out why this
happened and
uh they're kind of like conflicting
reports about what started all this
uh originally the report that i saw
online i think from the person who
who took the video i believe they said
it had something to do with uh
distancing or masking or something it
was like a dispute about that
um but then the cop said no it had
nothing to do with
with masking nothing it was not a racial
thing
there's no race no racial element what
they said
is that somebody had cut in line
so the woman the customer there
originally in the
in the in the dog pile she had cut in
line someone else didn't like that and
that's how the fight started
now i will tell you i don't condone
violence i don't
uh especially not at a bath and body
works we all know bath and body works
that's
not the place for that i mean walmart is
the place for that
but i don't condone the violence but i
will say
that cutting in line is one i don't know
if she actually did it
this is an allegation i don't know if
it's true i don't want to engage in
defamation here but
uh cutting in line if she did do that is
is one of the worst
sins a person can commit it is
almost as bad as ditching the shopping
cart in the parking lot
and a lot of times it's the same person
cutting lines the grocery store
ditched the shopping cart
in this case a little bit of street
justice um
dished out i can't say i'm going to
complain about it
that's all all right let's move on to
reading the youtube comments this is
from
km says um my wife didn't always get
along with my family but she never spoke
badly about them to anyone when she had
every reason to want to it's called
class something you don't marry a prince
for also
what kind of pans you have a husband
lets his wife smear his entire family to
the entire world
that gave him everything that was my
point yesterday one of my points about
the meghan markle interview that this is
your husband's family
that you're talking about
it's it's one thing if you have a
dispute i mean we've all had disputes
with the in-laws and it's one thing if
you hash that out with your spouse but
to go on primetime television in front
of 17 million viewers
and tell oprah about it what kind of
wife does that to the husband
but what kind of was a husband husband
what kind of husband allows that to
happen
what kind of husband lets his wife go on
national tv and
badmouth his family like that not the
place for it and i made this point
yesterday and a lot of people took
exception
with the with the word let's
i said this on twitter and there are a
lot of responses what do you mean let's
what are you saying that a woman should
have to ask permission before doing this
yeah yes that's exactly what i'm saying
i mean you should absolutely ask your
husband's permission
before going on national tv to talk
about his family in a negative way
or even in a positive way it's his
family
so yeah you should ask permission for
that to do it before doing that and it
should not be granted
basic common sense there i would think
jackson prouse says matt please don't
ban me i didn't know i was supposed to
salute you when when you said god speed
i was too busy weeping at the tragedy of
the show being over
i feel like you're trying to get by on
the technicality but i will
allow it joe says uh now joe is quoting
me when i said i never understood how
oprah became the big thing that she is
and joe's response is it's called food
matt
joe all right that
comment i do not condone
comment body shaming comments like that
i do not condone it at all
how dare how dare you joe i'm not gonna
have any of that here
um let's see
bill davis says matt i can tell you
sorry bill davis says matt i can tell
you truly are an asshat
and i most likely wouldn't want to be
friends with you or related to you but
everything you say is 100 right and you
make
you make me laugh out loud every day
i'll take it i will absolutely take that
and scott finally says matt please shave
your beard for a 200 000 subscriber
special well scott you're just begging
to get banned from the show and your
wish is granted
you are of course banned now i want to
tell you about a new sponsor on the show
that i'm very excited about total gym
the total gym fit gives me a full body
workout in the comfort of my home
for about half the price of these
expensive fitness bikes you could do
over 85 exercises on one machine whether
you're a beginner or advanced they have
everything you need
to get in the best shape of your life
burn calories and lose weight what makes
it so effective is it works every muscle
group
using 11 levels of resistance so you've
got a lot of
versatility a lot of different things
that you can do you can work your core
your arms your shoulders your biceps
thighs
literally your whole body and a couple
and a complete workout takes just 10 to
20 minutes per day what's great
is it comes fully assembled so you can
just take it out of the box and you can
start working out immediately
uh you know we're all busier than ever
these days it's hard to get to the gym
it's hard to find time for that and
that's why it's great to have the total
gym at home and you know i have it at my
home
the total gym fit and that's the best
thing about it is that it takes away all
the excuses you know that you have it
there you've got it you know in the
basement you got it somewhere in your
house in your room
and you can go and use it uh if you
carve out 10 or 20 minutes
i know you got 10 to 20 minutes to use
the total gym
uh the total gym fit you've got the 10
to 20 minutes go use it and get in the
best shape of your life right now total
gym
is offering a 30 day in-home trial on
the total gym fit for just one dollar
seriously one dollar so what do you have
to lose that's besides all those pounds
and no matter which total gym you try my
listeners
get an additional 20 off whatever
discount they're currently running just
head to totalgymdirect.com
walsh to get a special offer you must go
to this url
total gym direct dot com walls to get an
additional
20 percent off you know on election
night we announced that candace owens
would be joining the daily wire with a
new show
now the wait is finally over candace's
new show candice will premiere
next friday march 19th you may remember
candace from when um
cardi b ranted about her for criticizing
[ __ ]
or from haley when harry styles wore a
dress and uh
and candace famously replied bring back
manly men
many attempts to cancel candace owens
but you can't can't cancel
candace owens candace is also a founder
of the blexit foundation which works to
change the narrative that surrounds
america's minority communities
candace is also the author of the new
york times bestseller blackout how black
america can make its second escape from
the
democrat plantation candace will be
exclusive to daily wire members if you
are not yet a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candace to get 25
off again that's dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candice to get 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today it's time for a daily cancellation
that is sure to get me in trouble if i
don't handle
this issue tactfully uh and we all know
that i don't handle anything tactfully
so this will be no exception
we begin with a report from kctv it says
a missouri pastor is on leave after he
gave a sermon that many people say was
sexist misogynistic and inappropriate
pastor stuart allen clark took a leave
of absence tuesday from first general
baptist churchton
church in malden missouri located in the
state's southeast boot hill
after receiving widespread criticism for
a sermon given in late february in his
sermon
he explained that women need to lose
weight and submit to the sexual desires
of their husbands to keep the men from
straying
clark also said wives need to wear
makeup dress nicely have nice hair
and appear less butch now the article
goes on to explain that clark is now
receiving professional counseling
uh after getting fired and the church
has denounced his sermon
now we do have as you were hoping a
video of this sermon the whole thing is
pretty long but we could play the first
minute or so and uh here it is let's
listen
i want you to know a need that a man has
that he won't ever tell you about but
since i'm the preacher man i'll say it
your man needs an attractive wife
what anybody else thinks about well i
shouldn't say that
your man needs a needs an attractive
wife
a hockey player said he said i married a
trophy wife but now she looks like the
stanley cup you see what i'm talking
about
so i'm talking about all right that's
what i'm talking about
and ladies here here's the thing you
need to know about man
don't give him a reason to be like this
distracted boyfriend
you hear me don't give him a reason to
be
looking around hello don't do that
i've said this for a long time i'll say
it again it's free by the way
is i really don't believe women
understand
how visual men are i really don't
i don't think that i don't think i don't
think it's in their capacity their
ability to understand
how visual that men are i really don't
think women understand how important it
is
for a man to have a beautiful woman on
his arm
so there you go who's canceled here well
pastor clark is certainly canceled
normally i wouldn't insult a person on
the basis of their physical appearance
but if you're going to give a sermon
like that then you've invited the
observation that you
yourself are pudgy and out of shape not
to mention you're apparently wearing
jeans at church while you give this
sermon about the importance of
putting effort into your appearance now
it's possible the pastor isn't married
which means he would technically nullify
some of my criticism but still
married or not if you're going to stand
in front of a group of people and start
lecturing them about being out of shape
you better have your own house in order
your own waistline in order
all that said you know a million people
have already made this point about the
pastor he's lost his job he's a national
pariah he's in counseling
i don't think it's necessary to jump on
the dog pile like we're at bath and body
works there's there's
no reason why a bad sermon from some
random pastor to missouri needs to be a
national issue
i've heard many bad sermons in my day
there's nothing especially remarkable
about a bad sermon especially
or even this one um the reason i'm
bringing it up
is that it raises an interesting issue
because i'm also canceling many of the
people outraged by his comments
now as i said if you point out that the
guy is throwing stones
in a glass donut shop fine fair point
but if you claim as many people have
that it's not at all a woman's
responsibility to tend to her appearance
for the sake of her husband then i have
to disagree
i mean this pastor got it wrong because
he was making this a one-way street
exempting himself
apparently and it would seem men in
general
but the problem is that many of his
critics are saying that women simply
shouldn't have to worry about being
attractive to their husbands at all
and that's not right either the reality
is that spouses
both spouses both sexes should put
effort
into their marriage which means putting
effort into themselves and it's not only
about being physically attractive by the
way
it's your responsibility to tend to your
health so that you're around for your
husband in the long run
or your or your wife in the long run you
know
there's a good chance that in your later
years you're gonna have to take care of
your spouse
or your spouse will have to take care of
you and that's sickness and health and
everything that's part of the deal
but you don't want it to happen because
you neglected your health and abused
your body
so there are a number of very good
reasons for people in a marriage to do
their best to remain healthy and
to take care of their bodies this seems
again like some more basic common sense
and it is
but the problem is that people these
days tend to think that the highest good
is for an individual to live for
themselves even after they get married
they don't want to accept that after you
get married your life is not solely your
own anymore
your body is not solely your own anymore
now i know when i say that it sounds
shocking so your body's not your own
what are you talking
that only sounds shocking in a society
that fails to understand
refuses to understand the fundamental
point and purpose of marriage
if a phrase like your body is not your
own in marriage shocks you
i ask you to consider why it would upset
you if your spouse cheated on you
i mean what does the phrase cheated on
you even mean what exactly has your
spouse
cheated in what way have they violated
you
simply by offering their own body to
someone else
doesn't concern you what do you care
well because they've shown a part of
themselves they've given a part of
themselves
that they promised they would show and
give only to you their body is not
solely their own
they don't have the moral right in a
marriage
to go and give it to someone else by
giving their body to someone else they
have taken something from you
they've betrayed you why because again
their body is not their own every person
in the monogamous relationship agrees
with that statement
every single one if they didn't agree
then they'd have no problem with their
spouse going off and having sex with the
secretary or a co-worker or whoever
but every person in a monogamous
relationship does have a problem with
that
a very large problem which means they
believe even if they don't
know they believe it and they wouldn't
put it like this that their spouse's
body in some sense
belongs belongs also to them as their
body belongs to their spouse
not just body you know life everything
your entire person
body and all in marriage you pledge all
of yourself
body soul everything to the other and
that's the beauty that's the mystery
that's the joy the sacrifice
of the sacrament that's the point of the
sacrament
i mean it really has no point if that's
not the point
and all this means that yes part of that
deal take care of your body
take care of your health for your
spouse's sake
you know for your family's sake for your
children's sake so that you're around
for them and for your own sake
but again there are certain aspects of
this message that are difficult to
deliver if you haven't yourself
seen the inside of a gym since the
reagan administration and that's why
this pastor but also many of his critics
are canceled
this is called equity this is my version
of equity
when i cancel everybody involved always
fun to do that
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show joe biden can't
remember where he is or what he's doing
but his white house is doing an awful
lot of radical stuff and
the cdc deans to allow the vaccinated
just a little bit of freedom that's
today on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen